Canada's Arctic called remote
inhospitable but for Canadian Rangers
it's just another day at the office and
this is a job they volunteer for their
Canada's guardians of the North Canada's
eyes and ears in the Arctic hence their
motto vigilance the Watchers as climate
change opens up the Arctic for more
human activity the Canadian government
relies increasingly on the Rangers to
assert sovereignty in the north or for
search and rescue operations their
expertise in surviving and thriving in
this harsh and forbidding environment is
keen to Canada's ability to operate from
the Arctic the Rangers are volunteer
force most come from Canada's Aboriginal
communities the First Nations and the
unit all our experienced outdoorsmen
with a lifetime knowledge of living on
the land loans with Meg each Ranger
receives a world war two lee-enfield
rifles and gets trained in marksmanship
navigation first aid and search and
rescue in return the Canadian military
gets world-class guides and scouts not
long ago sergeant bill bud was hunting
Taliban insurgents in Afghanistan these
days is a ranger trainer but he says he
learns a lot more from the Rangers then
he can teach them how to look for a good
snow to build an igloo pay a lot of
mechanical stuff with the machines
they're really good at using very little
resources and actually fixing the
machine sometimes they'll actually build
parts out of you know simple objects
that you never think you could build a
part two to
going out of so little things like that
you know this is there this is their
playground and when we come up here try
p you know as much attention as we can
and it's a good it's a good payoff
because you do learn a lot of stuff them
they as well learn a little bit of stuff
from us too so so it's a pretty good
trade-off but being the Ranger is not
just for men pretty much all the patrols
have women in them and you know their
skill sets are are excellent to their
real asset to to the patrols there's
lots of things that they're just as
capable of doing you know it's pretty
tough living especially in none of it up
in the North here and the women are are
just as proficient with a lot of things
there is as though that I there but as
well culturally they have certain things
that they will do when a camp is set up
and then the men have other things that
they will do as well so they both have
that trade-off and that's what gets the
job done up here surgeon bud says the
Canadian military would be hard-pressed
to operate in the Arctic without the
Rangers I think we can operate in
terrain like this but I don't think it's
a wise thing because this is like I said
this is their playground and why would
you not use somebody that is familiar
with this type of terrain as guides as
Scouts I think it would be foolish and I
think this soldier that would have to
come up here and do that would be have
to be of a high high skill set he would
have to be trained by the Rangers and
then he may be able to do it but think
such as the ice out here definitely
these are the guys that that are going
to get you through and they're going to
get you through safe
whether building an igloo or reading
land and eyes Rangers pass on survival
techniques that the Inuit hunters have
perfected over millennia for the Inuit
the Rangers provide a valuable
employment opportunity in a region where
jobs are scarce and the skills they
learn save lives in their own
communities says ranger Adam from North
Tanaka who in his civilian life works in
the hamlet office of his native Joe
Haven guys usually go out on a line and
the family members call the search and
rescue and we get to go to car towards
where they were for ranger and Inuit
artist Bart connect the Rangers provide
a precious opportunity to pass on land
skills to the younger generation that
sometimes more familiar with an iPod
then the working and the Washington
rifle it would be good for because we go
out in the in a group there's other
people that with the older generation
has more traditional skills and he
learned that from the older people and
things like that because their life
style has changed rapidly woodgate a
unique generation for others being a
ranger provides a nice opportunity to
break the routine experience an
adventure travel to unknown corner of
Canada and I know
have some fun
you